the e use General Affairs Council has
examined a roadmap for the European
semester process which helps nations to
balance their budgets and strengthen
their economic policy the six-month
process began its fourth cycle in
November with the European Commission's
annual growth survey it ends in July
2014 when the Commission's country
specific recommendations are adopted I
was listening very carefully to the plea
coming from the member states that they
would like to have more of a European
level collective debates over the
country specific recommendations and
more intense communications with with
the European Commission and I told them
that I promised them that from from the
Commission side we are ready for it then
we will be following no surprise
scenario the European semester grew from
the economic crisis and a need to
improve national budgets and boost
confidence in the euro single currency
Europe's big challenge now is how to
sustain the nascent economic recovery
the roadmap for next year was drawn up
by current EU president Lithuania an
incoming presidency Greece based on the
lessons learned from the largely
successful exercise in 2013